okay this is the newbie versus the og
quiz what's my middle name no I know
your middle name I'm gonna make one up
Donna
no it's Marguerite it's a way to reach
that's my grandmother's name hi I'm
Megan and I'm joy and we're gonna be
interviewing each other for the 5,000th
show at the view now get things started
okay joy yeah congratulations on our but
it's really more your five thousandth
show Oh God you've been here the entire
time not really I don't bring up the
time they fired you because that's a
dark time it was not a dark time it was
a very bright time for the shot the dark
time for this shot yeah I don't like the
idea of the show without you why do you
think this show took such a nosedive
when you weren't here I think yes with
all due respect to myself and what's it
just that it also had to do it the way
they changed the topics and they made it
they made different our what they did
something I wasn't watching it they did
something else to the show that wrecked
it it wasn't just getting rid of me
although that was a big part of it is
huge disaster for everyone
why has the show lasted so long and been
so successful I think it's because of
the fact that we're unpredictable that
people don't know what we're gonna say I
think that's the main factor unlike
reality shows that are all scripted
we're not scripted who would you play
it's a pick to play me in a movie and
who would you pick to play you in a
movie
Oh for you I would say Scarlett
Johansson oh thank you for me at the age
I am now when I was younger
anything you want people say I look like
Bette Midler but I don't want her
playing I was gonna say like Julianne
Moore like some pretty resume yeah like
so who's the woman that was in Molly's
game she's a kakou Jack trous Academy
Award winner Jessica Chastain Chastain
those girls are not my type I would say
Marissa Tomei
I love mercy yeah more like that that's
a good one well Scarlett Johansson's not
my type you know but she sort of yes
okay we had matching Halloween costumes
this joy
great assistance depending on if you are
a Democrat coming on the show or
Republican coming on the show Joey or I
are your worst nightmare what are some
ideas for us to do together next year oh
well what about Kelly Ann and her
husband George Conway can you compete
George I'll be I'll be coming but I
might have to get a facelift I think she
had some surgery recently she looks a
little different her I shouldn't have
those bags under her eyes anymore what
is the one thing you want the public to
know about our relationship that we like
each other they keep writing things
about how we can't stand each other it's
really hurts my feelings it genuinely
hurts my feelings because our dressing
rooms are next door to each other and
you and I have the same emotional
reactions to things sometimes in
different ways but we're both upset
equally the equal amount of the same
things and I wish people would give us a
break whatever you think about the two
of us is that we really mean it yeah
what we're saying we really mean it yes
an act
we don't sugarcoat it we go right and
that's what we have in common and I
think there's mutual respect for that
yes and beg you're a true believer in
your ideology and I'm a true believer in
mind yes and both becoming a little bit
more not moderate but we've sort of
become I don't know what the word is
like we're not so adamant about our
positions like today I was talking about
how you know I I think a moderate needs
to win the amendment to beat Trump and I
think that originally I would say I
wanted Elizabeth Warren to win because
she was new stuff and she was exciting
but I'm not sure that she could pull it
off so now I'm in reality again and I
think that you have changed your
positions a little bit moderated them
I'm not and the other side a lot clearer
than when I was working at Fox yeah
obviously that just happens when you're
around a different environment and I
trust you with this I trust being on air
with you which takes time which is why
they shouldn't be firing either of us
anytime soon I'm not gonna but I trust
being on air with you and very serious
topics and intense topics and things
that are hard to talk about which that
only comes over time but I wish people
would give us a break too because I just
I don't think men would be subjected to
the same kind
even I remember something people like it
that we argue they like that but they
like conflicts if we agreed on
everything how boring we don't agree on
anything now how many times time is
during the show do you feel like
reaching out and strangling me no I
don't never that way I don't feel that
way I can't even remember the last
honestly we fight so much I forget like
and then I just move on right after a
long yeah then you're talking about the
trouble I don't know 2020 is not in the
band for you okay guys okay okay
it's our job to have debates and what's
the point of being like nice I also like
that you're not trying to be the sweet
girl and I'm not trying to be the
speaker either we're not trying to be
loved by everybody now that's also I
would get along it's very important when
you're on television and I noticed that
the most likeable people do not want to
be loved I don't want to be loved by
everybody the people who people like in
let's say in in the cinema even people
who just do the part they don't want you
to like them there must be something
that I do that annoys you sometimes
you're so rigid on issues but I'm the
same way
but I appreciate having a good sparring
partner and I appreciate that I think we
represent the two polar opposites in the
country and that it's healthy there's no
other place on all of television you see
two women like us debating issues and I
think that's really important and I
always respect you and this isn't just
they wouldn't put us in front of the
camera if it weren't authentic because
neither of us can anything not all it's
hard it's not I don't know you also and
we'll say this I've been doing this only
two and a half years this job is so hard
and every minute again I know we're not
like digging ditches or in Afghanistan
but it's a very challenging job and I
respect that you've done it so long
you're a TV icon your beloved by our
audience medal a lot of thought he can't
stand me I've read Twitter sometimes
don't read I see what they say about
people love you but no but you know it's
a it's a hard job but you know Allen
Aveiro said one day you guys take this
too seriously you know they put clothes
on you they put your makeup they do your
hair they give you research like when
she doesn't show at CNN she has to do
all of that by herself so in that way
it's an easier job that's a but it's the
emotional investment is what you're
saying because I could detach more yeah
I think it would be easier but I'm
incapable of that and I'm sick of being
told it's impossible well some days I do
I can do you are good you're better at
it I'm getting to be better at it I told
you you need a hobby off the air no
interest you as much as politics but
nothing does you have to find it no
nervous breakdown let me just finish
yeah part of your job is to listen to me
what's the hardest part of this job
getting a word in edgewise that is one
of the hardest part I think so yeah I
think it's like you have to learn I
always say this is a volleyball game
it's not a golf game and my good
volleyball player you have become so
good at it you'd like a gym now you know
yeah but that's the whole date to be
really bad well you didn't know how to
do the volleyball game in the beginning
you were playing your own game but now
you know because it's like bang the ball
around yeah now yeah you're quick it
you're quick with yours and also get in
and get out
don't don't hold the ball for 10 hours
yeah you do that very you have to do
that so what's the hardest part of the
job for you this is a very hard job no
it's hard it's very hard what's wrong
about it I think because you and I are
so emotionally invested in the topics I
get very upset or happy or it's like
lots of intense emotions on this show
and part of it is like the political
climate we're in and part of it is just
the nature of the show getting booed is
very hard I'm still not used to I don't
know when the audience does that what do
you want America to know about the view
and the 5,000 episode 5,000 episodes is
so long it's a long time it's almost up
there with Regis coming up next it's
Live with Regis and Kathie Lee is that
how long were they on it forever it
seems yeah and he people would come and
go with him but he always stayed do you
think this show will always be on the
air no no this show will not always be
instable climate change will destroy us
I don't think any show says on the air
forever except Jerry Springer he's still
there
well if you rotate the cast out yeah
then maybe well they always said this is
a franchise this yeah and you just said
will exists but it really I don't know
if that's true I think that the this
particular group has a lot of good
chemistry yeah it would if you don't
have a good chemistry the show will go
off the air but I also think we've been
through a lot in the Trump years and I
think it's like this specific moment in
time makes us all bond together because
this show is such triggers for the left
and the right and people go crazy for
all of us and I think you have to be in
a team too
right that's true I do know that he's
certainly it's helped the media it's a
phony scam it's all ok this is the
newbie versus the og quiz this is kind
of heart though when's my birthday is it
soon it's close to we have this or
similar we're like we're all like libra
Scorpio woman jerk oh yeah you're right
was the last guy you're right before
mine I'm like sober seventh what are you
twenty third right near each other yeah
okay what college did I attend Columbia
I knew that that's it that's I think
that's it here's my newbie quiz for you
okay
how many seasons have there been of the
view 23 yes that's right what was the
year the view first aired I don't know
seven I think it was set in 97 and 98
it's thing is that not good okay she's
right yeah okay which host has sat at
the table for the most number no you
know that answer yeah that's me Kendall
oh gee yeah can you name seven for
review house not including the current
table there are thousands of us so no no
come on Lisa Ling okay Barbara Walters -
oh my god there's been so many Paula
Faris nicer names for three more only go
back more go back Meredith Vieira five
two more Oh Rosie O'Donnell six Rosie
Perez seven there you go okay all right
okay thank you which former co-host went
on to host a major morning news show
Meredith yeah she did yes no you don't
tell you something the day that she left
I cried that was the only time I've ever
cried on this job what I cried because
she was my only pal she's my your pal
yes you're my pal now why would you cry
she was she was my friend I cried that
day she's a lovely she is a great yeah
how would you rank this table cuz you've
had so many tables of like how good you
think it is in comparison nothing will
ever compare to Elizabeth when she was
here but regarding work just like how
good the table was that was like the
glory you loved that table I love that
table I love that table with you and
sharing and Elizabeth and Rosie
O'Donnell and Barbara Walters really not
yeah I loved it but that's like when I
was in college and I watched oh yeah
I consider that a very contentious
people probably consider this a
contentious they've always been like
that it is what it is people can't they
put us at the table and they say have at
it yeah we surprised I've laughed it
over two seasons no I knew you would
last because you have energy we need
energy on this show you know you want
people to watch how much do you want to
strangle me sometimes that's why you
talk about guns that's the only thing I
can't get through an abortion that's
what everyone gets the most mad at me
Horsham makes them mad at you almost mad
yeah and gun guns that's the one because
this ar-15 thing has got to stop and you
know it yes you to stop it I don't know
I might take away guys but um when
you're not here I hate the show I mean I
really have a heart as everyone knows
I'm a really hard time when I can't
fight with you I really enjoy it I
really enjoy being friends with you oh
you're really funny I like you always
make me laugh on the show
I'm really very insincere Lee I'm very
grateful that you're on the show with me
and I give all the answers I do I love
joy and really that's because neither of
us put up with neither of us care about
being loved and both of us don't want
our husbands on the show every day
that's good so we have a lot in common
we don't drag our husbands out like
props neither of us do that oh my
husband he thinks he's Howard Hughes I
know my knee that yours either but yours
is a TV personality what he does not
gonna come to the show
I think it's weird he's not like they're
not our accessories I don't need like
I'm married it's fine right you're
married just yeah yeah yeah if he does
that your middle name is Marguerite
that's actually and very Spanish thank
you it's my mom's mom and grandma same
the 108 year old she's Roberta
oh that's Roberta I don't like Roberta
because it's really Robert and then I
like my real name is Josephine Joseph
and then clean it's really not a right
thing to call a girl by a boy's name and
then add something to it wins names
Rowena Rowena mm-hmm
two R's all right dad and I learned I
learned that you and I agree on a lot of
stuff we do wait I knew that before but
I'm
I just appreciate that whenever
something happens breaking in the news
and I'm upset I can always count on you
being upset that's true you get as
emotional as I do and everyone else has
calm and measured and looking for the
bright side and we both think the
apocalypse is slowly coming any day now
so you can catch all of this wonderful
talk on the views we just have our own
show if you want to see more of this but
louder with more interruptions and being
played out by music on occasion check
out the view every weekday at 11:00 yes
oh we like this because we're we're a
team
[Music]